and now it's time for bumming reviews
and if Chester a bum
tonight's review x-men first class did a
dear spoilers there's this guy named
Magneto
oh he's not Gandalf in this movie she's
a tiny little boy in the concentration
camp
oh and there's this Nazi who's a bad
daddy crazy the Nazis are always the bad
guys and he makes a deal with little
magneto moving at coiner us I'm going to
shoot your mother hey that's good just
move it into my cup why didn't you say
so how long you think that's gonna fill
the dolphin I'll try to kill ya oh good
I can't tell you another little boy
named Xavier only she is in jean-luc
Picard's yet he's also a tiny little boy
he comes across a tiny media took a who
later girl to not be so tiny and son
little Xavier is just looking at you you
were saying about your parents I think
what okay cool so Xavier grows up into
mr. Tumnus and a little girl grows up
into not quite as hot as Rebekah remains
nameless but still pretty hot to her
brother and sister now didn't know that
I mean who grows up into a very angry
person who wants to destroy every Kevin
Bacon Nazi he can find which is good
cause I hear there's only three so the
CIA discovers that means exist and they
discover that Kevin Bacon is immune who
wants to start a war between the USA and
Versailles because he's tired on the
world playing the game six degrees of
Kevin Bacon
he always wins all the time apple pie I
like apple pie one degree I win so
xavier magneto joined forces to stop the
evil Kevin Bacon Nazi Xavier is like
control your power you must first
control your anger
just like how I control my hair loss why
is it I don't trust you and they come
across another mutant named Hank McCoy
hey where is everybody calls it based
why because Beauty and the Hank my
quarry doesn't sound as catchy but he's
gonna be dead he just his hands on his
feet
ally head hands on my feet once then I
took him off oh yeah Wolverine has a
cameo hey will breathe okay wait wait
you know this is pg-13 right I'm only
saying it once good you know Bridget
so the Kevin Bacon Nazi gets help from
this woman named Emma Frost we can turn
her entire body into diamonds oh my god
she's one of the vampires from
Twilight's stunner pretentiousness what
you got alive so Xavier gets all these
other young Young's together but then to
Kevin Bacon Nazi trap spying and he's
like oh then these popular mutants step
forward to join my team why because
you're probably gonna die and you're
expendable I got more screen time than
Hugh Jackman wait a minute Darwin and I
can't let this happen
darling what do you do I evolve can you
evolve from this like only new you
pretend minutes a week because I only do
it for nine so now the x-men are really
pissed off and want to go after the
Kevin Bacon Nazi so they start training
themselves to be tough and fine it's not
so bad to be a mutant except for Hank
he's a bit of a winner that's why I
created a cure to stop it
oh wait silly me instead of reversing
the mutation it does the exact freaking
opposite how could I miss that I think
I'm a bad scientist so the Beast turns
really hairy and everybody's like don't
feel so bad what day James Cameron will
want to write that off so the x-men are
officers stop the war between the
Russians and the USA in everybody's
flying around shooting missiles at each
other and then the needle comes across
like Kevin Bacon nutty and just what
magneto has him exactly where he wants
him he says I'm gonna count to three and
move this point
oh so many don't steal just be romantic
helmet I mean you know is like we must
stop them before they fire their
missiles at us but I say girls like you
they're not gonna fire their missiles at
a spy our missiles I thought bookie
you're really not helping
but maybe they'll take the missiles and
throws it right back at them and Xavier
is like your jerk you're a jerk but so
many fighters are gonna make me I like
to do these things to pull it into a
saviours backside I ain't had a bullet
in my back sight once never call Ted
Nugent funny-looking so Xavier falls to
the ground I can't feel his legs anymore
which is weird seeing how he can control
the move other people yet he came with
his legs I don't know and I neither was
like fellow mutants you are either with
me or against me because I serve you
Charles even though you're my brother
you can't walk anymore and I have
motivation to go with him I'm going to
go with him for some reason I'm totally
cool with this okay bye but that Xavier
is like oh by the way a long time from
now when I lose my hair and you look at
that older is there any chance we can
put aside our differences for one day go
to a girl's house and say wow she looks
incredible and act like we're friends as
long as we can go back to being enemies
immediately after that goes without
saying
don't Xavier opens up his school freaks
and geeks magneto goes to get Emma Frost
out of jail
hey sorts of continuity is totally
screwed hurry so obviously they're gonna
make a kinda sort of sequel out of this
kind of sort of prequel following this
one kinda sorta makes money and there's
only one way for that to happen oh come
on I promise I'll give it to the movie
makers come on change
what if I promise to get gambit in the
next movie I'll change it from a
10-minute cameo to an 11 minute cameo
quais if the Nazis are always the bad
guys I don't know what I'm gonna put
that in my god